where is the mark is the question - yeah
so there's there's certainly some
questions some big questions that need
to be answered as far as how why what
when where what you know what's what's
gonna happen whether or not it it
becomes a some sort of a interconnection
because deem did where the mark and now
the mark is essentially the key to
whatever this was there might be a
connection what I don't know I haven't
seen it I haven't seen in the first four
episodes but there have been some
flashes of things that Dean some
premonitions so to speak you know I I
don't think and I hope he doesn't cuz
I'm kind of done playing the guilt that
Dean feels I think he's over the guilt I
think it's like look I made my bed I'm
gonna lie in it like we've got we've got
the darkness the mark is gone where you
know you're not you don't have demon
blood I don't have a mark like where
we're back to normal we're in the car
we're fighting a common a common target
let's just let's just deal with it the
way we always deal with it and and keep
pushing forward and so I'm excited about
you know what that scenario and what
that gives us is a story what it's what
we're going to be dealing with I I'm not
quite sure yet good question that's
actually what I asked when I read the
script I'm like uh can this happen and
they said well we're gonna we're gonna
figure that we're going to deal with
that and what the repercussions are
obviously the repercussions at the mark
we have the darkness what the
repercussions of killing death are might
play into that so well like I said it's
you know they're not afflicted with
anything they're not fighting to save
one another they are fighting together
their whole again
and they you know they've got a mission
and I think that that's gonna lend
itself to much more kind of season one
relationship you know they had a common
purpose it was to find that now they've
got a common purpose it's to figure out
what this is how they're gonna deal with
it and do that and so I I feel like it's
gonna be a much more brother centric
kind of show this year I think there's
gonna be alliances made that probably
wouldn't of if they're if something this
big and this the scale hadn't have
happened what those who those alliances
are I don't know but from what I
understand they're they're not they
wouldn't be an obvious choice for an
alliance so I'm excited to see who that
who or what that might be so it's a bit
of a bit of a expositional episode it's
it's moving the story along as to what
the different you know factions of the
storyline are is happening where they're
going what's gonna happen it's there's a
lot of information divulged and in our
episode there is there are some some
things happen to a few characters that
may or may not be good for the story
yeah I'll say that it's the third
episode so just you know whatever has
been happening has been happening for
three episodes so it's time for some
things to to occur and there's a few
things that do occur
you